servet sg zh und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video im heutigen video
reden wir über entscheidungen und über
eine sehr wichtige entscheidung in
meinem leben die ich getroffen habe als
ich aus der schule raus bin und dann so
vor dem nichts stand um mich fragen
musste okay was macht jetzt eigentlich
meinem leben dazu machen ob ich jetzt
zeichnen kann so oder so leute wie
übrigens erst mal aus drama live bei sky
über dem moment als ich fertig mit der
schule war um mich fragen musste was
mache ich jetzt mit meinem leben
und zwar heute ist das video von teilt
das ist eine marke die unter an diese
stücke herstellt gesponsert deswegen
werde man versuchen mit diesen stiften
zu malen obwohl ich darf müsst euch
einstellen der schlechteste male aller
zeiten bin ihrer echt schön aber wenn
ihr jetzt in der schule sei dann ein
alltägliches leben ihr erinnert euch das
leben ja genau und zwar gibt es ja immer
irgendwelche leuten der schule lisa ich
kenne überhaupt nicht mehr setzen sie
sich hin dann sagst du ja okay zeigte
machen wie schlechte mainz und der
marine
mona lisa du denkst du so auf jeden fall
bin ich keiner von den leuten ich kann
eigentlich nicht meint aber trotzdem
letzter
einmal wird die fröhlichen letzte musik
zwei mal kleiner pisser zeit also werden
wir den kleinen essen das bin ich
der kam gerade aus der schule herzlich
vorgemacht das abiturzeugnis halter von
lehrer bekommen
mit den worten hier news
auf jeden fall nachdem er sein zeugnis
hatte hatte er viele viele fragen was er
jetzt mit seinem leben so machen möchten
wir diese frage wieder recht bekommen
hat und auch deine stirn effekt bekommen
hat warum sollte ich das heute wieder
drehen aber leute ganz ehrlich lassen
wir das tier mit dem droh mail hilft der
liebe leute eine sache die man nie
unterschätzen darf ist dass junge
menschen wenn sie mal mit der schule
fertig sind egal ob sie abitur macht ob
sie einen hauptschulabschluss machen
wolle optionen realschulabschluss machen
am ende sitzt irgendwo mit der schule
fertig und sie sind fertig mit der phase
im leben wo leute einen immer gesagt
haben du musst das machen da musste das
machen da musst du das machen man hat
das irgendwie so gelernt einfach das zu
machen was andere sagen und dann kommt
diese melodie hat keinen schulabschluss
und auf einmal sagt euch keiner mehr was
ihr machen sollte niemand sagt mir muss
das und das studieren oder muss auf
jeden fall unbedingt lieber eine
ausbildung machen und über genau diesen
moment wo man eigentlich überhaupt keine
ahnung hast du mit seinem leben machen
soll und der auch überhaupt nicht leicht
ist ehrlich gesagt reden wir heute bei
mir war das so nicht weiß ich hab ich in
meinem video gesagt hat dass ich einfach
nach der schule sind überhaupt kein plan
hatte was ich machen sollte ich hätte
wirklich überhaupt kein plan zunächst
lustig tragen ich war einfach so
komplett ohne idee sei erst ein jahr
später sebastian hat immer noch nicht so
wirklich eine idee aber hat jetzt
zumindest mal schon irgendwie mit grob
seine universität an der gerne studieren
möchte problem aber die universität ist
sehr weit weg und zwar 400 kilometer
das heißt dass ich als ich noch bei
meiner familie gewohnt habe die
entscheidung treffen musste ok der orden
in süddeutschland ist jetzt irgendwie
eine universität die mich interessiert
ziehe ich jetzt 400 kilometer weit weg
und heute reden wir über diese sehr
beängstigende entscheidung so weit weg
zu ziehen und was passiert wäre wenn ich
diese entscheidung nicht so getroffen
habe freue mich den ganzen geschwafel
loslegen es gibt am ende des videos noch
was zu gewinnen
also bleibt auf jeden fall dran
ich musste mich sagen was ich hatte
damals wirklich schon ein bisschen
schiss vor der entscheidung so weit weg
zu ziehen gab besonders einem punkt wo
ich mir dachte ist dass sie das richtige
so das war nämlich als ich mir wohnung
angeschaut hat hier unten also deshalb
bin ich 400 kilometer von zu hause
weggefahren um irgendwelche wohnung
anzuschauen und dann war ich so hier in
dem ort wo ich jetzt schon seit drei
jahren wohne und hab mir bono angeschaut
natürlich wenn man irgendwo hin zum
studieren muss man sich da auch wohnung
anschauen und ich weiß noch wie ich hier
rum gelaufen bin und ich mir so dachte
er ort hatte mir nicht wirklich gefallen
und es war irgendwie komisch aber
letzten endes habe ich seinen job
gemacht und haben in diesem moment zwar
sieht man nicht auf mein bauchgefühl
gehört weil keine nachricht ab ist es
einfach immer verwirrend wenn man zum
ersten mal von zu hause auszieht und
dann irgendwo hin zieht dann ist der ort
immer so vital überwältigend aber leute
unser ein zu können ob das einzig
richtige entscheidung wurde nicht muss
man sich eigentlich überlegen was wäre
wenn ich nicht mehr bezogen werden und
das ist so eine sache die man sich
eigentlich überhaupt nicht vorstellen
kann dass es unmöglich sportfeld weil
ich mich so sehr persönlich verändert
habe seitdem ich hier studiere auch
dadurch dass ich so weit weg bin so
viele neue freunde gefunden habe so viel
dazugelernt habe es ist jetzt so wenn
ich zurückschaue leute und so vergleiche
wie ich vor drei jahren drauf war als
ich mit meinem studium angefangen habe
und wie ich jetzt auf bin
das sind einfach so total
unterschiedliche personen und mein
jetziges ich gefällt mir viel besser ist
wegen kann ich glaube ich für mich sagen
obwohl ich damals so richtig richtig
richtig richtig viel schiss hatte davor
wegzuziehen und irgendwie eine
unbekannte stadt zu gehen auch als ich
mir die wohnung am schalter so ein
komisches gefühl hatte im nachhinein war
es auf jeden fall eine gute entscheidung
für mich aber in dem moment was wirklich
schwer da will ich gar nicht lügen leute
ich weiß auch dem moment als ich dann
hier runter gezogen bin ich bin damals
mit dem fernbus umgezogen und zu dem
moment als max mich damals zum bahnhof
gebracht hat und es für mich dann hieß
okay bis jetzt hier aus dem ort und
schießt ein ganz neuer das war echt
schon sehr heftig und sehr emotional
aber mir geht es gut mir geht es viel
besser als damals
ich habe jetzt einfach mal total kreuz
und quer von dieser geschichte erzählt
ich hoffe man kann das irgend verstehen
wie gesagt jetzt am ende daraus zu
gewinnen und zwar haben die leute von
peine seite eingerechnet yaez www.ad
minister eine story punkt de da können
die so kleine spiel spielen und zwar
besteht die seite aus videoclips und
nach jedem video clip könnt ihr euch
entscheiden aber die story einrichtung
oder die andere richtung laufen lassen
wollt und wenn ein quasi nach ihrem clip
auch entscheidung getroffen hat und
gesagt hat okay diese so weiterlaufen
dieser so weiter laufen lernen könnt ihr
eine menge stoff gewinnen unter anderem
acht playstation 4 12 bose lautsprecher
und eine menge anderes zeug und zu jedem
gewinnen gibt auch eine packung von
diesen tieren stiften dazu und erläutern
6 ab wenn die einschaltung treffen bord
und gucken wird wie eine story läuft der
link zu der ganzen sache mal der ersten
stelle in der beschreibung also wenn ihr
doktorvater und bis zum nächsten mal